es ist tatsächlich so zumindest hier in
deutschland ist die epidemie außer
kontrolle und auch den anderen ländern
sieht es nicht gut aus ist es völlig
unbekannt wer wen angesteckt hat wer der
oder die patientin 0 ist und wer danach
angesteckt wurde
und das hat folgen heute sind zum ersten
mal mit 427 mehr infizierte außerhalb
von china gemeldet worden und in
deutschland haben die beiden schwer an
cupid 19 erkrankten bereits tagelang
infiziert am gesellschaftlichen leben
teilgenommen alle prognosen bewahrheiten
sich in diesen tagen eine pandemie
scheint nicht mehr aufzuhalten zu sein
und die für quarantäne zuständigen
gesundheitsämter in deutschland sind
schon jetzt überlastet krieg zum science
fiction gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in den letzten
wochen ist man ja immer mal wieder
panikmache vorgeworfen worden
aber jetzt bewahrheiten sich alle
prognosen und andererseits haben andere
wiederum versucht zu verharmlosen beides
ist nicht okay ich will hier einfach
sagen wie es ist ohne panikmache ohne
verharmlosung beides hilft niemandem
und ja wir haben einen hang disruptive
informationen solche die unseren
bisherigen erfahrungen widersprechen die
wollen wir nicht wahrhaben aber manchmal
ist es einfach so und beim corona virus
ist das der fall und ich kann es nur
immer wieder sagen wie schon seit wochen
alle fachleute aus der epidemiologie
sagen dass sich diese epidemie zu einer
pandemie ausweiten wird warum das so ist
kann jetzt an den beiden schwer kranken
patienten in nordrhein-westfalen
beobachtet werden die beiden haben knapp
zwei wochen am gesellschaftlichen leben
teilgenommen
mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit andere angesteckt und
die beiden haben sich wie super
verbreiter verhalten die ehefrau ist
kindergärtnerin
sie hat noch lange infiziert gearbeitet
was gestern noch seltsam klang die
schließung aller schulen und
kindergärten im kreis heinsberg macht
jetzt extrem sind über die kinder in
dieser kita und deren geschwister könnte
sich das virus schon an zahlreichen
anderen einrichtungen verbreitet haben
das ehepaar hat zudem noch an einer
karnevalssitzung teilgenommen sie
könnten und dass es eben nicht
unwahrscheinlich das virus an hunderten
menschen weitergegeben haben zudem wer
hat das ehepaar angesteckt
er ist hier patient null vollkommen
unbekannt auch sie oder er könnte
weitere menschen angesteckt haben es ist
tatsächlich der worst case eingetreten
die ausbreitung ist außer kontrolle im
wahrsten sinne des wortes ist es völlig
unbekannt wer wen angesteckt hat wer der
oder die patientin 0 ist und wer dann in
folge angesteckt wurde
kogit 19 ist im vergleich zur gruppe
deutlich tödlicher und deutlich
ansteckender weil niemand antikörper
gegen das saas kopf 2 virus hat gegen
grippe können wir uns impfen lassen
sprich und das muss man sich vor augen
führen im gegensatz zur grippe an der
meistens kommen mehr als einige
hunderttausend erkranken und nur 0,1
prozent sterben steckt sich bei coop 19
mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit jeder an der mit dem
virus etwas intensiver in berührung
kommt und die sterblichkeit die
mortalität liegt mindestens zehnmal
höher wahrscheinlich sogar 20 und mehr
mal höher und wir sind nicht gut darauf
vorbereitet wie gesundheitsminister jens
spahn behauptet zumindest die
gesundheitsämter sind schon jetzt
überlastet martina hammel leitende
ärztin im gesundheitsamt marzahn
hellersdorf hat jetzt in der berliner
morgenpost alarm geschlagen bei ihr
seien elf von 22 stellen nicht besetzt
die hälfte und eine ähnliche situation
gibt es flächendeckend in deutschland in
den 400 gesundheitsämtern ist die zahl
der ärzte innen zwischen 1995 und 2014
um ein drittel zurückgegangen und die
gesundheitsämter sind für quarantäne
zuständig laut martina heinl werden die
ämter sehr schnell mit einer corona
epidemie überlastet sein es gibt noch
sehr viel zu sagen und deswegen wird es
hier am samstag ein special zusammen mit
dem neuen kanal ein fach medizin geben
alles was du über corona wissen muss
wird es heißen und schon jetzt gibt es
bei einfachen medizin die besten infos
corona virus was ist wirklich tödlich
anklicken anschauen und einfach medizin
abonnieren bis dann bleibt